if you've never watched what i've done
on america's got talent
in 2018 they recruited they looked at
they went to roast battle and they said
we want someone to come and roast the
judges and so they had a few of us
audition
and i said look i want to do it but let
me show you how i want to do it
and i showed him the character wearing
my tail and all that
and i was like look for a show like this
this is how it's going to work you can't
just have
me looking like an angry [ __ ]
you know retired porn director go up
there just like
hey uh heidi klum you're [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] like it's gonna look
awful but if you do it like this and
make it really silly
it might work and so i went out there
and
it's a theater 3 000 people right and
you know this is the biggest stage i've
ever been on
this is the biggest show pretty much in
the world
essentially and i went out there
and had my ass handed to me harder than
any person i pretty much know has ever
had on stage
for seven straight minutes the audience
booed and
screamed at me violently to get off the
stage
and the judges are pressing their
buzzers one by
one and i'm i start with tyra banks and
i'm just going down the line and after
every single person they're just like
buzz
and the people like i can see everybody
and they're all holding their hands up
in giant x's
they're screaming at me i can't even
hear myself think but
simon is laughing his ass off and won't
press his buzzer
so i'm up there you're supposed to be up
there for two minutes
i was up there for seven it was awful
and i walked off stage and finally like
you know it was all over
i got through it and i just like walked
off stage and i was like what is that
gonna look like i was so i cried on the
way home
because that level of negative energy
is impossible to avoid it was swirling
through me
like i had done the worst drug i've ever
done in my life i felt sick
like i thought i was going to throw up
and it took
days to get it out of me and i forget in
there for two and a half months and for
two and a half months i'm going what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do
what is this is if they air this i'm
[ __ ] finished like i'm gonna look
terrible people are gonna think like i'm
just i i don't know what it's gonna look
like
and then it aired and the internet
[ __ ] spoke up and they were like this
is
legendary this is the coolest [ __ ]
thing
we've ever seen on this show because it
got it's not for the people that watch
the show
yeah it's for the people that don't
watch this don't like this show
yeah those people on the internet so
they started sharing the clip going dude
look what he did to these people
he went out there and shoved it in their
face and these people were just in love
with the judges or something
yeah 100 dude yeah they're like they're
this kind of crowd where like
the people that love that show love it
so much
right they don't want you to talk down
on it and of course
they're idols dude they're icons and so
i was like and so suddenly realize and
they the thing is the show
really respected what i did because they
understood the value of it
you have to either kill on that show or
do something extremely memorable in a
really different way you can't be middle
of the road
because middle of the road doesn't make
good tv and they realized that what i
had done
had never been done on that show before
and
next thing you knew like they edited in
a way where i just look like i know
exactly what i'm doing
you can't tell that i'm freaking the
[ __ ] out inside of me yeah
so man i got off that show but like so
then all of a sudden
the views started popping and i mean
it's now
i think all of my clips on that show
have like over 100 million views in
total
just because awesome yeah because that
show is so it's so big but that clip got
passed around all the people that don't
watch it but then this year they invited
me back
to do it all over again because they
realized there was merit
in it and the judges were like i was
like
they'll know what's coming this time
they can't they can handle it so the
judges that were hitting the buzzer why
were they hitting the buzzers
because they oh because i'm talking [ __ ]
dude like i do i started
the first thing i the very first thing i
said was to tyra banks who is the host
first of all i come out there with and i
say i'm here to inspire the world
through happiness positivity and comedy
and they're all cheering like
everybody's like yeah mel b the spice
goes like i love this
yes and then i turned to tyra banks and
i said
tyra you have so much courage it must be
so difficult to host a show like this
and still find a way to make it about
you
and everything from there yeah
then everything from that point on was
like oh [ __ ]
like it was you know mel b i said like
uh
miss scary spice the only thing scarier
than you is your solo career
um and then the the one i got the most
flak for which is one of my favorite
jokes i've ever written i said
heidi klum you are magical four children
yet your body appears that you haven't
paid attention to any of them
and she looked at me and just went bam
and buzzed so quick like but simon was
ready for it he was
ready to take it yeah that's awesome he
talks [ __ ] on people
right he does that i was like these
people talk
ruin people's dreams all day
they these people come out on stage
thinking that they're about to have
their life changed and they just look at
him go
you're terrible yeah that's soul
crushing if you're not expecting that
but someone like me who's had been
through the ringer of rose battle so
many times
i was like you know can't hurt i'm all
right
you know it it hurt it hurt though yeah
but
to it also i was like oh well now i'm
resilient
like nothing like that is ever going to
happen again who that what i think about
is like
who can say they've been booed by that
many people like individually because
even like as
sports teams you're with a team of
people you go to another city
and that city's like hates you but
you're with your team
right right you and all your boys right
i was by myself
oh god dude so that's got to be an
insane feeling
oh the worst that's got to be insane but
to get that come back this year and be
able to do it again even though i didn't
have an
audience that i made the quarter finals
this year i was in the top 25. that's
awesome so like it was one of those
things where it's like
i got mine because and i made people
understand
that this is something to be valued and
that's really what happened
when i hit the internet is people said
like don't all these people
like these these celebrities shouldn't
be upset
who is this guy they've had 40-year
careers of
nothing but success they have so much
money they have
everything why do they care that this
little [ __ ] a tale
is saying these things to them you know
and that's
that's kind of the beauty of it and kind
of like sparked conversation of like
you know shake things up dude is it
gonna be the same
judge uh judges this time when you go i
already did it oh you already did it
yeah i did 2020 i did it i ended up
doing
um two performances but my first one was
on march 14th which is when lockdown
started so i'm
so now i'm in the exact same theater and
now i'm looking at instead of um
heidi klum was sick so she wasn't there
mel b had been cut off a couple years
ago
so now i'm looking at howie mandel sofia
vergara who i
[ __ ] love more than any i'm like she
is my dream woman
um and simon and in in the same 3 000
seat theater
there are now three people looking at me
and i'm doing and i'm doing the same
thing
that's weird too awful yeah right yeah
just again like i'm like this is
this is i i was ready for this
experience i was ready for these people
again
i was ready to laugh in their goddamn
faces and flip my [ __ ] tail at them
and just like and because they weren't
there though
they also could really understand what i
was doing yeah and they could hear
the jokes properly and really it made it
so they were like
they were all like this is really funny
this is great and so then i just kept
moving through
and the final performance i did on the
show um for the live shows was
one of the things i'm most proud of in
my comedy career and
um i read i won't ruin it but i
basically i read
a storybook of rose jokes to them with
illustrations of the jokes popping up on
a giant screen behind me
and it's i'm so proud of it and
i really feel like i got mine and that
show
as many people the good thing as many
people shouldn't go on that show
you have to make it work for you and i
found a way to make it work for what i
wanted to do without having to
compromise who i was
right yeah i was very long-winded i'm
sorry i took all that time
that was [ __ ] great yeah that was
great what a great [ __ ] story man
i